okay I did not see that coming
so the first trailer for the New Mutants
is out and yeah that's different before
I get into this I do want to say I have
not forgotten that I said I was gonna
start doing episode by episode reviews
of Gotham I am gonna get to that
but life has gotten in the way I am
basically caught up now but I also know
I am absolutely gonna miss next week's
because I'll be out of the town
vacationing so after that I'll do like a
summary of what I thought are the ones
up to that and that I'll move forward so
but this right now this had to go up now
this could not wait so talking about new
muse Oh New Mutants is a title that's
been around for a while and it's one
that I honestly had pretty much zero
interest in because I'm like what the
heck are they gonna do in what way is
another team of teenagers gonna be any
different from the x-men series popper
like maybe back when you know it was all
like the more grown-up versions but
we're all we've got younger teen ish
versions of you know a lot of the
characters we know so how is New Mutants
gotta be any different well drastically
so cuz it is a whole new ballgame in
terms of tone this thing incredibly
horrid twinged it's funny because on the
surface the took the two halves of this
the New Mutants as characters and a team
of them is not some am particularly
interested in a bunch of young people in
a weird creepy possibly haunted Hospital
thing not a scenario particularly
interested in for some reason you put
both of those together and they become
greater than the sum of their parts and
I'm like I'm immediately intrigued by
this and I I had to double-check like
who the characters were that they were
playing cuz they don't they don't really
show off any of their powers they show
plenty of weird stuff going on but you
don't know if it's being caused by the
kids or something else going on so we've
got characters like magic and Wolfsbane
and sunspot cannonball and Mirage most
of whom are characters I know I'm like I
used to seeing them like this so I'm
just you know what
props to Fox on this which is not a
sentence I ever thought I would say
here's the thing
seeing this does not make me suddenly
think that Dark Phoenix is gonna be good
I still stand by my video as to why Dark
Phoenix will suck however I really have
to applaud Fox in terms of what they're
doing with all of the spin-off and not
the main series of x-men films cuz I
mean Deadpool was very much his own
thing and was really enjoyable really
energetic Logan again very much its own
thing a heavy divergence and legion was
amazing I'm hearing good things about
gifted haven't seen it yet and now this
it seems like Fox does superhero movies
best when they aren't actually making
superhero movies you give them you know
I superhero property and land when they
do something that isn't just making a
superhero movie they're coming up with
some really interesting stuff and I
think to me it is saying like unless you
need to to retain the rights maybe let
the main franchise just quietly die cuz
first class was good and I enjoyed Days
of Future past but apocalypse was
abysmal I have no real hope for Dark
Phoenix and the thing is there when they
make those they're trying to play
Marvel's game and I know Fox has been
doing it longer because the x-men series
dates back to 2000 but Marvel is doing
it better right now my when it comes to
straight forward superhero movies Marvel
is really on its game right now and Fox
trying to compete with them and play
that same game they can't do it so when
they win is when they do movies that are
very clearly not playing that game even
though they are using superhero
characters and again this fall is very
much in line with that and I do get a
bit of a Legion vibe I don't know if
that's only because of the sort of
mental hospital setting that might be
because Legion is a bit more of a trippy
vibe less of a horror one I have to I
loved Pink Floyd's album the wall so the
use of that
fought at the end and this this cover of
another brick in the wall part two yeah
that's uh that's that's that's gonna
that hits me right there and I'm kind of
biased in favor of that but aside from
tone there isn't a ton to go off of here
I mean we get very little storm you know
they are mutants they're in some sort of
facility things are going weird but
that's about it like we don't really get
a good sense of the characters or too
much of anything else and a lot of the
imagery while a little bit unnerving
none of it stood out to me although
there is one thing and this might just
be to the benefit of the trailer and the
way the trailer was cut but it was a
really lovely contrast with just the
calm way the doctor character goes you
should try to get some rest and then it
cuts to one of them with this math and
with this sort of breathing thing on the
face like I'm like oh that was a good
image to cut to from that line so I
don't know if that's uh if that
transition of you know calm voice to
that imagery is in the film but if it's
not props to the trailer makers on this
and just like I said I'm really
intrigued by what Fox is doing with
everything that isn't the main x-men
franchise and it makes me happy that
they actually continue to control x-men
I get a video about this before but
without reiterating all that like this
Disney would not make this and so I like
that Fox still has control of the x-men
because they are do they are branching
out and doing things that other studios
aren't doing when it comes to comic book
and superhero related characters they're
expanding genres in a way that most of
the rest of them are doing I mean Disney
and the Marvel movies that they have
they have made as much as I love them
dearly they are you you can identify all
of them as superheroes even the ones
that like are kind of subgenres so like
supernatural superhero superhero heist
superhero you know espionage movie some
of these things that have been coming
out of from Fox related to x-men you
would barely describe them as superhero
movies at all I mean Logan there's
nothing I mean
guy happens to have powers but it's a
stretch to call that a superhero movie
definitely said the same case with
Legion and I'm just really enjoying
watching the the way that these
characters can be used get expanded and
if Marvel isn't gonna do it because they
have no incentive to they've really
they've really kind of nailed what it is
they are doing so they don't have a
massive incentive to diverge from that
and DC and Warner Brothers they're still
figuring out what they're doing so if
it's gonna fall to Fox to really push
the envelope in terms of taking these
characters in these sorts of things and
tropes in other directions by all means
let them do it if they could hand
Fantastic Four back tomorrow though that
would be lovely
so I think that's about it like this
trailer yeah I'm not sure it's a great
trailer in and of itself but in terms of
just coming out of nowhere and making me
pay attention to a movie that I was not
gonna pay attention to yeah job
definitely done there so I'm really
intriguing I'm gonna be really curious
to see the next trailer that comes out
on this one so the new mutants trailer
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts were drop something down
in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher
I'm also 1/2 of the punch like a girl
podcast available on the fire water
podcast network
Fire & Water podcast calm thanks so much
for watching and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]